[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and there's still
some life in the old girl yet with the
Walking Dead being resurrected across
screens everywhere just in time for
Halloween the first episode of season 10
is just dropped and the debut has a hell
of a lot to impact from it there's hints
towards the eventual direction that the
show is going to take and where the Rick
Grimes solo films could be heading
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the initial episode of the season
as well as why it's ending teases now
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch the
premiere yet then I highly recommend
that you turn off now that's your last
chance to back out but without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
click in this video now let's get into
the Walking Dead Season ten we last left
our cast of characters at the end of
season 9 with a warning from alpha to
never enter whisper territory again not
only did the villain decapitate all of
the show's c-listers but she also led
Daryl to a hoard of walkers that she
threatened to unleash in the group if
they didn't heed what she said
it looks like alpha knew that this would
fall on deaf ears and we saw her
preparing for what will be known as the
whisper war in the climax of the finale
and heard a mysterious voice on the
radio that showed their world was about
to become a lot bigger season 10 picks
up in the aftermath of this with the
whisper Wars slowly being teased
throughout the episode the episode
itself kicks off with a satellite
crashing on earth which not only shows
that the people who were lucky enough to
be in space during the outbreak are
probably now all dead but that the
entire world has been brought down by
the walkers whilst I'm sure most people
already knew this the fall of a Russian
space station makes me think that the
show runners are lacing this with some
anti-trump russian metal I'll just stop
there before we get too deep anyway the
satellite causes a huge forest fire at
one point which again is pretty relevant
to our modern day but unlike the
survivors this never forces to walk into
our territory it's a neat way to open
the season and it feels like the old
world is finally truly gone with its
monuments and Technology crashing to the
ground
the
episode truly kicks off when we get some
awesome Walker action early on and from
the off it feels like the Walking Dead
is back in full swing as we watched some
awesome deaths that feel like they were
ripped straight out of Resident Evil 2
however it's not all fun and games and
slicing a zombie's head into three and
throughout Episode one you really get
the feeling like the survivors are
throwing caution to the wind and
contemplating taking down the thing
that's causing so much fear in the camp
this is exemplified by Aaron who says
he's sick of being so goddamn nice and
that he's not alone he even takes on a
group of walkers by himself to prove
that he's better but before you can say
we're not going to take it we cut to
Rosie as sob love triangle that's really
getting out of hand at this point she's
got sadik's baby has a will they won't
lead thing with gabe and eugene is just
waiting for everybody else to die so
that he can finally escape the
friendzone we learned that carol is
taking her break up with Zeke in her
stride and that she's been on a boat
like a Lonely Island video is sailing
around which is probably the best
strategy to take in this entire thing
she reunites awkwardly with Zeke and
Daryl and Lydia too seems to be fully
integrating with the camp and we even
discovered negan is slowly winning
people round now that Rick's gone I
really hope he gets his moment to shine
as he was the villain that I used to
love to hate but now he's the villain
that I love to love he knows what it's
like to lead in this newfound world and
I think after having learned from his
past mistakes he could truly step into
his own in this season anyway back to
the forest fire and in order to
extinguish it the group have to go
straight into alpha territory Eugene
seems to be partly stripping it for
parts and we see Carol and Daryl go away
to discuss running away to Mexico
together even though it's probably just
as bad there as it is here it's not the
get-out-of-jail-free card anymore guys
anyway at the gorge we see alpha wand
around and she locks eyes with Carol and
the two stare each other down there's so
much awesome subtext to this moment and
you really get the feeling that alpha is
so angry inside even though her face
doesn't really change all that much the
two stare at one another and just like
that the whisper war has begun and it's
time to rally the troops cancel that
trip to Mexico because this is about to
go down
it's owned now how could things go ahead
going forward well it looks like the
next episode of the season is going to
be from the whisperers perspective and
instead of watching our heroes rally the
troops it'll be the enemies that we take
the POV of the only reason that I think
this is happening is because we will see
firsthand just how well-equipped the
whisperers are and it will lead to
another major defeat for our survivors
at the hands of them we know that she's
cleared the gorge out now and is really
going to hit the survivors as hard as
she can now where does Rick play into
all of this well we do see Judith
lovingly spreading his legend almost
like she's a disciple of Jesus and I
think after the survivors defeat when
they are at their lowest that he will
come back a legend reborn resurrected if
you will he's just like Jesus and he
will inspire the survivors to fight on
whilst I don't know exactly how they
will explain why he's been the zombie
version of the dad that's popped out for
a pack of smokes and decided not to come
back I think this episode was a really
enjoyable one I've been criticized in
the past of dinging The Walking Dead for
being bad but this one feels like a
great setup for what's to come I can't
wait for the whisper war and if season
ten delivers on its promises then we're
in for a great time
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on episode 1 and what you hope to see in
the future drop them in the comment
section below and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of this
weekend's big releases Joker which would
be linked at the end I go over the
hidden twist in the movie that you
missed so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more about the
real meaning behind the film if you want
to come chat to me on Twitter then make
sure you follow me at definition whitey
you have discord and want to talk more
about movies so make sure you click on
the link in the description section
below you've got an awesome community
and it's the best way to stay up to date
with the channel also just want to let
you know that we're currently giving
away a free copy of spider-man far from
home on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning it so
liked this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on episode 1 of The Walking
Dead in the comments section below the
winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from the end whoever gets
surprise so best of luck to everyone who
takes part
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]